I mean it's the same thing that Terry
Gilliam said to Quentin Tarantino or
Quentin Tarantino said your films are so
specific and they're so they're they're
they're they're they're there is such a
vision behind them how do you do that
you know and Terry told him
Dave Fincher said that he didn't know
how to create a script I think you were
talking about that and that he didn't
know how to see the big scope of a whole
film he only knew intuitively how to
direct a scene or a sequence
and he was in awe of screenwriters
and what they were capable of
yeah I believe when he was talking about
that I think it might have been the
making of social network
and I think it had to do with the
intricacies of writing dialogue and the
snappy way that opening of social
network begins where it's them sitting
in a coffee shop and they're going back
and forth and I think he was talking
about the idea of filming that for I
believe 62 takes or maybe the numbers
off it could be a different number of
takes but quite a few takes and
[Music]
um
and the concept that he can't
necessarily sit down and ride out 120
page script but he can intuitively
understand where to place the camera and
how to capture the emotions of what's
taking place
um I can't remember the context in which
I was talking about that but I believe
what it would have to do with is just
the idea of choosing the right placement
of camera and movement versus the
emotional stabilities you're trying to
harness and capture in performances
and David Fincher is one to watch with
the idea of
how he's you know pushing the camera
through so many different shots I mean
there's something about his execution
that is such
a David Fincher execution
um
that's so unlike everything else
everybody else makes which is so
interesting but I can't recall where
where what I was saying that in regards
to though
yeah if you watch The Social Network and
then you watch let's say um girl with a
dragon tattoo would you see the same
sensibilities oh yeah two very very
different films oh yeah very very I mean
he barely ever has handheld camera work
his cameras are very situated to
whatever it is if there's movement if
it's connected to a vehicle it's
you know the best shot it seems like his
films are executed in a way that they
are the best executed films out there
like but I mean that maybe has something
to do with him doing so many takes
though I don't know
and when I say executed I I really don't
mean I don't mean that his choice of how
he films something is the best I just
mean that it seems like somehow his crew
is executing at a higher level than
everybody else's
which has got to be a testament to him
or a testament to doing 60 takes of
something
yeah I don't know did you do a lot of
takes with clowning no
we did I try to do three to five if I
could
um we had so little time I mean like the
interrogation stuff all through the
movie clowning we we that was 12 Pages
we had to shoot all in one day
yeah we had to shoot all that in one day
because we only had the Sound Stage for
that one single day
um yeah that whole movie was driving
more time than acting in front of the
camera which that's why my next film or
any feature film I never want to do in
less than 30 days
switch to Martin Scorsese he was talking
about how 34 days was like no time
you know he he would not want to do one
less than 60. he said that an interview
I was watching for uh the Irishman
yeah I mean it's talking about that
movie and I just I thought to myself he
said I can't do a movie in less than 60
days and we just got done doing this
17-day shoot and my thoughts were like
man if I had 30 days that would have
been a completely different movie but
but I also believe that restraints guide
you to the solution
so I wouldn't have wanted to make
clowning any other way than what it was
made I'm extremely proud of what it is
um
and if it would have had a different
amount of money or a different amount of
time it would have been a completely
different Tale
and that goes back to the Buddhist
saying of work with what you have truly
but also too it goes back to the idea of
just go make a film
because as long as you take the camera
get the people go out into the world
you're gonna find a gorgeous way to
shoot it and you're gonna get those
Little Miracles that happen and they
only happen if you hit record
if you don't have recorded it never
happens
in hearing this David Fincher quote or
paraphrasing of the quote what are your
thoughts on someone at his level saying
that he's in awe of screenwriters being
able to do what they can do when we see
what he does and it looks so effortless
well I would say that
that's a a master of his craft truly
expressing the truth which is if it's
not for the written word we wouldn't
have a movie you can do a whole film
improvisational for sure John cassavetes
and plenty of filmmakers have proven
that
but
you need the written word you need
something to lean on and like you need
the written word generally for investors
not everybody's Mike Lee where Mike Lee
would go to investors with a group of
actors and say this is going to be the
subject here's the actors give us money
and then they'd go off for five or six
months and formulate the characters and
make these brilliant films
the truth is is that when it comes down
to it
you have to understand or let's say it
this way if you can compartmentalize
your abilities and comprehend what
you're best at and then fill the slots
with amazing talented people for the
things you're not that great at then
more than likely you will succeed
because I mean it's the same thing that
Terry Gilliam said to Quentin Tarantino
or Quentin Tarantino said your films are
so specific and they're so they're
they're they're they're they're there is
such a vision behind them how do you do
that you know and Terry told them you
don't have to worry about cinematography
or knowing lenses or knowing production
design you just have to have your vision
you just have to have to see the thing
the way that you see it whether it's
colors angles everything all the
pre-visualization methods you can think
of if if you're able to go down that
path and then you fill all the people
around you with the most talented people
you can possibly bring together then
they're gonna make you look amazing and
they're going to bring your vision to
fruition because you have to have a
vision for it to be a vision right
because a vision truly what a vision is
is the final filter for all the choices
and if somebody doesn't have the vision
then it goes back to what Andrew
tarkovsky said in his book sculpting in
time he says if the director is not
careful you can become a mere witness to
your movie being shot to your actors
acting to your production production
designers designing to you know and and
the but for him what Andre tarkovsky
believed is that the director should be
more of a poet more of an artist and
have their hands dirty and everything
constantly and that's what David Lynch
did he was constantly seen on set
messing with everything building a lamp
for the background of a scene and you
know but again there's different kinds
of filmmakers I don't think David
Fincher is building a lamp
but he's choosing the lamp
and therein lies what your real
objective is and the objective is to
have a vision